I agree. And if you see things the way I
do, with continuity, you know, look what
happened to the Eastern Church, and I
already told you the Islamic conquest in
the 7th century swallowed up three
quarters of what was Christendom. What
makes you think it can't happen to the
rest of it? It's already happening to
it. Again, the problem is too many
people think of, you know, North Africa
and the Middle East was always never
really Christian. I'm telling you it was
way more Christian than the rest of
Europe, much more Christian, okay? And
the only thing that was comparable was
Rome, okay? So, you had Rome, but then
you had Antioch and Alexandria and
Jerusalem and then later Constantinople.
All of those were conquered by Islam.
So, you think it's it's just, you know,
fate that the rest of Europe can never
be conquered? Is especially when you're
going out of your way to allow it. So,
yeah, the fates of both are actually
intertwined, and, you know, I gave you
that Teddy Roosevelt quote, the reason
that Europe managed is they fought tooth
and nail. That quote where he says that
the reason Christianity remained in
Europe when it was conquered everywhere
else is cuz we fought. And now you're
seeing in slow motion time the exact
opposite where Westerners and Europeans
and Christians
are falling over and suicidally inviting
Muslims in to take over without a fight.
And you think Muslims are going to be
demoralized and they're going to leave
Islam right now? This is the most
moralized they've ever felt. This is
They're watching history unfold that
their strong, powerful enemy, the
infidel West, is is just accommodating
them and acquiescing to them. Yeah, that
that's because Allah's on their side,
just like the original Islamic conquest.
It's the same logic. They see it. So,
yeah, inasmuch as Islam wins, it's not
going to lose converts or or actual
people, Muslims. Bring
back the
fire.
Bring
back the fire.
Bring back the
fire
and
the righteousness.
name.